[Musique]
tout
booba il s'est rendu compte que dans ce
système là tout est faux ce système
rapidement après un nom pour lui qui est
magali berda il y à une femme juive
success x men qui s'est fait tout seul
cloué au pilori sur les réseaux sociaux
pour les influenceurs la a fait gaffe il
est sourd aux côtes il va pas vous
lâcher et tout ça a commencé parce que
monsieur elie yaffa qui est plus connu
sous le nom de booba a publié sur
twitter à la mi-mai des photos d'un
procès verbal qui divulguait des
informations personnelles de mais
gilbert d'amélie berda donc demandé à
monsieur vie afin de retirer cette
publication et ça a complètement
dégénéré et c a commencé tout simplement
sur réseaux sociaux et booba a découvert
qu on ne proposait d'investir et qu'en
fait tout était faux et il pensait spray
ans avoir un interlocuteur il a
rencontré un système ici il avait
commencé à s'en prendre à ce type qui se
présentait comme une star de
l'investissement des et du trading en
fait il ya un système derrière ce
système rapidement après un nom pour lui
qui m'a galibert barret et de susciter
chez naïve
[Musique]
el berda
reçoit des dizaines de milliers de
menaces de mort notamment à caractère
antisémite des dizaines de milliers d'
injure notamment à caractère antisémite
son numéro de téléphone a été divulguée
de sorte qu'elle a reçu des dizaines et
des dizaines d'appels téléphoniques
malveillants et de sms malveillants son
adresse a été divulguée de sorte qu'elle
a dû déménager en urgence voilà c'est
incessants cet incessant
[Musique]
il y a
une procédure en cours une plainte qui
était déposée auprès du parquet de paris
et je n'en dirai pas plus parce que je
suis tenu par le secret des enquêtes et
par le secret professionnel maghribia
apparemment a déposé une plainte pour
cyber harcèlement et pour appels à
l'aide
[Musique]
c'est une première victoire judiciaire
bon
non ces faits aux autorités une autorité
administrative qui s'appelle dgccrf et
puis on va aller devant la justice on va
montrer au procureur de la république on
va montrer ce que nous comprenons de ce
système qui commence d'un côté avec un
influenceur et qui va juste et un réseau
social qui est très contents d'en danger
et de vente de l'audience et donc du
profit comme cela et on va demander à
chacun d'assumer ses responsabilités il
dénonce particulièrement le drop
shipping qui a décidé aussi vite qu'il
le comprenait qu'ils comprennent ce qui
lui arrivait de mettre tout le public au
courant parce que
s'il ya un système d influence qui
consiste à accuser des gens à la vendre
n'importe quoi sans aucune vérification
ça ne fait que quelques jours on est le
19 juillet où le 20 juillet ça ne fait
que quelques jours qu'on entend parler
du placement de produit et de drop
shipping donc le fond du problème n'est
pas celui là mais puisque vous en parlez
madame berda n'a jamais été mis en cause
par d'un point de vue judiciaire pour
des placements de premier frauduleux ou
pour le cpf des fraudes au cpf ou je ne
sais quoi elle était exemplaire c'est
simplement que c'est un nouveau métier
c'est une nouvelle activité économique
qui est récente donc on peut pas tout
bien faire du premier coup la société de
madame berda shauna event apprend au fur
et à mesure des de ces pratiques
évidemment qu'il ya des fraudes dans ce
milieu que le drop shipping et
condamnable le titre mais madame berda
en tant que
influence heuzé madame berlin en tant
que responsable cgt cheminots evans n'a
jamais jamais été mis en cause pour les
pratiques de la sorte jamais
[Musique]
ils ont porté plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse parce que je ne supporterais
pas que pour se défendre de ce qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle organise 2 qu'elle
profite madame d'art de la puce accusé
par exemple booba d'être antisémite ça
je ne le supporte pas et je ne laisserai
pas faire oui je ne laisserai pas plus
l'accuser de cyber harcèlement il a
jamais diffamation de la part de madame
berda ya jamais eu de dénonciation
calomnieuse une dénonciation calomnieuse
ça supposerait que les faits que nous
avons porté à la connaissance de la
justice ont été dénoncés dans le but de
nuire à monsieur yaffa donc c'est la
justice qui décidera si les faits que
nous avons dénoncé des mérites ou non
des poursuites
[Musique]